[Música]
a 115 metros de altura se levanta
majestuosa mente el árbol más grande del
mundo una cebolla serpe bivens que se le
va tocando el cielo del parque nacional
red bus de california
este extraordinario espécimen lleva el
nombre de imperium el titán hijo de
urano el cielo y gea la tierra su nombre
significa el que camina en las alturas
pensemos por un momento en este antiguo
bosque todas las especies de árboles
experimentan condiciones similares en
cuanto a los recursos requeridos para su
crecimiento
sin embargo imperium ha sido el único
árbol de su especie capaz de alcanzar el
máximo de su potencial desde muy joven
sentí fascinación por la naturaleza eso
me llevó a querer estudiar biología y
entender qué es eso a lo que llamamos
vida en el 2006 cuando se publica el
descubrimiento de imperium quede
conectado a especies extraordinarias
como están para mí siempre ha sido un
enigma y una gran motivación que me han
llevado a querer estudiar cuáles son las
bases biológicas y psicológicas de
aquello que nos hace excepcional
cuáles son las condiciones requeridas
para alcanzar nuestro máximo potencial
es interesante observar cómo a lo largo
de la historia distintas personas
gracias oa pesar de su entorno de
crecimiento han logrado elevarse y
caminar en las alturas la clave de este
enigma está en la materia invisible esa
sustancia imperceptible a nuestros ojos
que atesora nuestro máximo potencial de
ser saber y hacer para encontrar esa
sustancia invisible hay que dejar de
mirar hacia afuera y comenzar a mirar
hacia adentro alguna vez te has
preguntado a dónde vamos cuando cerramos
los ojos
por momentos todo se oscurece y luego
después de unos segundos comenzamos a
percibir destellos de luz y colores que
nos da la sensación de estar viendo con
los ojos cerrados esta es la clave
permitirnos estar en un estado de
introspección en el que nos aislamos de
los estímulos exteriores y sentimos
percibimos y nos adentramos al interior
de nuestra mente
es allí cuando entramos en contacto con
la materia invisible y nos da la
oportunidad de poder conectar con
nuestro potencial creativo al cual
accedemos a través de la imaginación en
los últimos años la práctica del
silencio y la meditación han demostrado
ser un camino que nos puede conducir a
estados de armonía interior
en mi opinión una de las razones por las
cuales se tiene cierta resistencia a
estas prácticas es porque se requiere
que nos sentemos cerremos los ojos
respiremos y alcancemos un estado de
quietud algo a lo que no estamos
acostumbrados parar parece que no es una
opción dedicamos mucho tiempo a observar
la vida de otros y eso hace que de
alguna manera vivamos más en el exterior
que en el interior
la vista se ha convertido en nuestro
sentido favorito interacción con el
mundo nos hemos hecho esclavo de los
estímulos visuales las imágenes lo que
percibimos como bello el sentido de la
estética está todo condicionado a
nuestra observación constante del otro
esto no es un juicio de tus hábitos
sociales es más bien una invitación a
descubrir quiénes somos en realidad
la información de quién soy que siento
solo la puede encontrar observando y
sintiendo mi propio ser no se trata de
ser individualista o aislarnos se trata
de poder conectar con nuestro potencial
personal para crecer y generar valor al
mundo
esta capacidad es necesaria sobre todo
cuando vivimos momentos incertidumbre y
caos
el caos es el sospechoso habitual a
todos nuestros problemas cuando en
realidad es una condición natural y
necesaria en nuestras vidas
el miedo no tener control imprime una
realidad llena de fricciones que limitan
nuestra capacidad de imaginar y crear
nuevas posibilidades crear estructuras
dentro del caos puede ayudarnos a
amplificar nuestras habilidades y
ayudarnos a alcanzar nuestro máximo
potencial de crecimiento
alguna vez has pensado en que quieres
cambiar de vida crear estructuras para
propiciar el cambio es el primer paso en
cuanto al tiempo para cambiar eso
depende de cada quien hay personas que
necesitan el caos para movilizarse
buscar oportunidades y hay otras que
requieren estabilidad el caos y el orden
están conectados por un mismo camino que
transitamos de forma pendular entre uno
y otro estas estructuras te pueden
ayudar a pensar con claridad en momentos
de incertidumbre y con profundidad en
momentos de orden y armonía
que nos hace ser excepcional esta es la
pregunta que conecta a toda la historia
existe una diferencia importante entre
capacidad y habilidad la primera tiene
que ver con lo cognitivo y nuestra
capacidad de saber y conocer y la
segunda tiene que ver con lo conductual
y nuestra capacidad de actuar es la
universal relación entre aptitud y
actitud he buscado un método que sea
fácil de aplicar el resultado de esa
búsqueda es el modelo imperium en honor
al titán dios de la sabiduría y la
extraordinaria ese cuello rojo el método
tiene cinco dimensiones que funcionan
como una suerte de guía en momentos de
incertidumbre la primera dimensión es el
adn mi premisa es que así como en los
genes se encuentra toda la información
de aquello que posibilita la vida en
este metafórico adn que se denomina
atributo distintivo nobel se encuentra
toda la información de aquello que te
hace único y excepcional este atributo
es tu habilidad natural es algo que
muchas veces haces de forma inconsciente
sin embargo cuando este atributo se
manifiesta genera gran valor en las
cosas que haces y un efecto en las
personas con las que interactúas muchas
veces es aquello por lo cual las
personas te recuerdan la segunda
dimensión es la del conocimiento
intensivo y representa
valor del conocimiento que posee una
persona si lo pensamos como un
coeficiente como el intelectual o el
emocional representa la profundidad del
conocimiento que una persona tiene lo
convierte en un experto y lo diferencia
del resto cuando nos interesa un tema
dedicamos muchas horas a aprenderlo la
curiosidad se incrementa y queremos
saber más es en esta dimensión donde se
fundamenta la capacidad de querer
adquirir un nuevo conocimiento que
eventualmente puede ser de valor para el
mundo la tercera dimensión es la
propuesta única de valor está la idea
sobre la que la mayoría de las personas
construyen su marca personal y
profesional cada día muchas personas
lanzan sus productos y servicios al
mundo hay mucha oferta mucho ruido y
eventualmente todo parece lo mismo lo
que genera una gran presión por
diferenciarse y ser únicos antes de
seguir con las siguientes fases vamos a
integrar las tres primeras descubrir tu
atributo distintivo nobel permitirte el
tiempo para sumergirte indagar un nuevo
conocimiento nos puede ayudar a
construir una mejor propuesta de valor
mi amigo alejandro loguercio a los 13
años fue a la orquesta sinfónica escucho
un concierto que cambió su vida un año
más tarde cuando tomó su violín en las
manos
esa experiencia no solamente selló su
vida sino que le permitió descubrir su
adn veinte años más tarde de arduo
trabajo le ha permitido tocar en
orquestas alrededor del mundo todos
nosotros conocemos personas como
alejandro personas excepcionales que han
integrado las primeras tres dimensiones
y que de alguna manera han vivido la
vida que desean si no nos permitimos dar
ese salto de conciencia de alguna manera
nos vamos a quedar atorados en la
tercera dimensión creando una propuesta
de valor que es insustancial y que no
tiene nada que ver con quiénes somos en
realidad la cuarta dimensión tiene que
ver con el desarrollo de habilidades
para el servicio futuro la pregunta más
importante es qué estás haciendo tú
ahora para mantenerte relevante un
futuro tan incierto mantenernos
actualizados valiosos y relevantes en un
futuro lleno de incertidumbres
obsolescencia destrucción creativa
disrupción tecnológica e inestabilidad
económica es de vital importancia la
quinta y última dimensión es la auto
trascendencia ésta incorpora la idea de
ir más allá de tu propio yo grandes
autores de víctor franz abraham maslow y
pamela rita han trabajado sobre este
concepto esta dimensión incorpora la
idea
de ir más allá de tu propio ser elevar
el nivel de conciencia una forma
práctica de poder entenderla es pensar
cuál es el legado y el valor que le
quiero dar al mundo esto se lo pregunto
mi amigo óscar pérez marcos cuando
peregrinado en el camino de santiago
oscar ya lo había intentado todo desde
emprender hasta trabajar en una
corporación financiera las personas y
las historias que conoció en el camino
lo ayudaron a salir del sendero que
estaba marcado tomó el primer avión a
áfrica para llegar y vivir una
experiencia significativa hoy en día
oscar vive en pro de servir al prójimo y
de vivir una vida con propósito esta
historia nos muestra el camino inverso
del modelo como a partir de un ejercicio
de auto trascendencia podemos llevar a
desarrollar nuestra capacidad de
servicio futuro para crear una propuesta
de valor única recuerda que no importa
dónde o cómo te encuentres todos
necesitamos buscar una manera de ser
mejor desarrollar nuestras habilidades y
ser felices en el proceso espero que
esta estructura te pueda dar certeza
controlar algunos aspectos de tu vida
desarrollar tu máximo potencial y
alcanzar tu mejor versión a mí me ha
servido como marca experimental para
pensar con claridad en momentos de
incertidumbre y con profundidad en
momentos de equilibrio
es una guía que me sigue cuando cierro
los ojos respiro accedo a la fuente de
mi potencial creativo y me preparo para
el futuro hoy tenemos que tomar el
control de nuestras vidas dejar de mirar
tanto hacia afuera y comenzar a mirar un
poco más hacia adentro es la hora de
elevarnos todos tenemos la capacidad y
las habilidades para poder caminar en
las alturas
[Música]